it's my pleasure now we're going to kick
off the neck
I owe the title of his talk is crushing
the head of the snake I think he's going
to get into a few analogies that he's
got baked into that kind of clever the
so Robert is the chief architect at
crunch thought I oh where he works with
brilliant statisticians and developers
on analytics as a service he's also the
lead developer of cherry pie a leading
HTTP server and framework for Python um
I want to know to it the first thing I
heard Robert say as I walked up here was
will the clicker work with linux so he's
he's a developer's developer I think
this is going to be a fun talk and I'll
pass it off to Robert thank you I have a
mic thanks Robin I guess you could call
me a developer's developer but I really
want to talk to you guys today not as
super geeky developers I hope this talk
is useful to you if you are what I think
I see mostly at this conference which is
you know I'm a scientist or I'm a
researcher or I'm a grad student or
whatever and I'm not a programmer so you
know maybe you could don't have a CS
degree and haven't encountered a lot of
the common solutions for really common
problems so what I'm going to try and do
is just give you a little introduction
to some of the ways to kind of tame
Python because it is really powerful and
it does a lot of good things for you out
of the box but you can still do really
stupid things with it especially if
you're used to coding and C or some
other language you know you really want
to learn kind of some of the ins and
outs of just Python itself and then
there's also some general programming
techniques that we're going to go over
that are that can really help you get
your work done better and faster okay so
let's get started one of the things I
want to really talk to you about is you
know the the problems of big data are
really unique depending no matter what
you call big you know as a birch was
saying this today there is you know it's
really that my memory is small not that
my data is big so you're going to run
under the same problems no matter what
and you could read you know
reams and reams and stuff about how to
make Python do what you want but some of
those things really apply to big data
problems you know and all the stuff
about natural language processing maybe
you're not doing that you know and all
stuff about you know literate coding
well maybe you're not doing that so so
one of the big problems with big data of
course is performance for 8 so what you
need to be able to do with your code in
python is be able to figure out how to
make it faster so there's really two
primary tools we use for that in the
Python world first one is time it and
this comes from Python it's just built
in not to import I mean you don't have
to install anything and Python comes
with this time at module and this is
really good for answering their question
how long will my algorithm take right
and so time it gives you just a really
basic timer class and you pass it some
arguments the first one here is what's
the code I want a time that's the first
string here where it says range a and
then the second argument is what kind of
setup do I need to do to get ready to
run my code that I actually want to time
so that's just preparation so what we're
doing here is we're using pythons range
function which just makes a list a
sequential and so are set up in this
code here is we're going to make we're
going to make a variable that says a
million and then what we want a time is
how long does it take to make a list of
that many items so how long does it take
make a list of million items in Python
going to be different on every machine
but in mine if you run this once it
takes twenty eight milliseconds to make
a million element list and Python out of
this range function right and you can
pass you know different different
amounts to time it so you can see how
when it's one hundred or a thousand
times it kind of scales up pretty linear
linearly although not completely we'll
talk about that in a minute and then the
default argument for time it is a
million so I really want to caution you
if you're using time it don't pass no
arguments to it first always pass the
one first just in case what your timing
takes six days you don't want to wait to
find out how long that takes
so do one first and then work your way
up but for now we'll just we'll do it
with you know a million because we're
doing really simple things here so what
you can do with time it is say well have
I have two ways I could write this which
one's going to be faster right that's
the great thing about time it so you
could say well it takes me so long to
make a thousand element lists I've heard
about this cool thing called X range
which you know kind of iterates over
this and gives me yields values to me
rather than returning whole thing I've
heard that's faster let's find it if it
is and so we time that and see how much
faster that goes oh and it turns out
that's a lot faster so yeah I want to
use X range everywhere and then you have
to be a little subtle in your use of
these tools because it's really easy to
kind of misguide yourself with time it
and say hey I just found something
that's faster i'm going to rewrite my
whole code basin and make that you know
use that well you have to be a little
cautious because it turns out that it's
it's really fast to make this X range
thing because it does almost nothing
until you try to iterate over it and
then it makes then you start yielding
these values right so when you actually
do that with this list operator down
here list function it turns out that
iterating over that list can actually
take more time than if you just use the
range function but the point here is
that time it is really a good way to
compare functions one of the time so one
caveat with this is that time it does
have some overhead and it's it's not
going to give you the time of just what
you want to run but it there's a little
bit of overhead from the time it module
itself okay so this is how long it takes
on my machine to do nothing a million
times takes twenty nine milliseconds so
if you really are you know benchmarking
something on a production box you want
to find out how long it's going to take
you might have to subtract this out just
something to be aware of and then
finally it's wall time which means you
know how far is my minute hand moved on
by my clock on the wall not how how hard
it my cpu work
which means if you if you use time and
you start to type something and then you
find out oh well you know somebody sent
me an email and I'm going to go download
this video and watch it you know while
my timer is running it's probably going
to affect your times because it's going
to use up cpu and other resources on
your machine so what that means is that
random things that are happening on your
machine at the same time really affect
the times here so it's totally okay to
run a time timeit loop you know a few
times and take the smallest number
that's the one that you want to go with
to compare because maybe the first one
here which seemed to take a little bit
longer you know maybe i was reading some
email or something the same time or or
something's happening in the background
at my machine so take the minimum and
time it gives you this repeat function
which makes it really easy so what this
is saying is do this a million times and
do that three times and give me the give
me the times of each of those runs so
that's that's a great tool and then you
might say well okay i'm actually i'm
using time at and I'm timing you know my
functions different ways of doing this
thing and those are actually really
complicated and I want to know why is
this one slower than the other or what
part of this is actually taking all the
time and for that we need a little more
sophisticated tool than time it that's
going to be the profile module in Python
what you should always do almost all the
time is not import profile but import
see profile because it's a lot faster
has lower overhead just start with see
profile and you'll be happy okay but the
basics of see profile it's very easy to
use we're just going to import you know
my module import see profiling and call
this run method and again the first
argument here is well what am I actually
going to profile and so I'm calling some
b function in my in my mod module that's
what this is doing and then I always
recommend starting with this sort equals
cumulative parameter and I'll show you
why in a minute but it's just there so
you know that it's
so the way this works is you know a lot
of times is you're just developing one
implementation of your logic you run it
you see how long it takes you see where
the bottlenecks are then you go back and
you make changes to your code run it
again ok did I improve and you look at
the outputs of both of these and I'll
show you that next so when you do that
you have to reload your module in Python
or unless you're starting a new process
but if you're just doing this all on the
interactive interpreter you go make
changes to your code until you call this
reload module function you're not going
to see the changes in your in your
current session so always do the
reloading and then just run the run the
profile module again and see what the
help looks like so this is what the
outputs like a lot of stuff there and
this is a really tight example so
there's even less a lot of stuff there
than usual so here's what we're doing
have a little more complex thing that
I'm profiling right now so we're just
doing a for loop and then we're making
some lists and then we're sorting lists
so the second line there you can see how
many function calls total did this make
and how long did that take total and
then we see it's ordered by cumulative
time so just to quickly orient you to
the output here if you haven't seen it
before I think it's backwards I always
like to start from from the right hand
side here and say well what what were
the actual functions that were called
that were used in my whatever I'm timing
and then the first thing I always like
to look at is this cumulative time
column okay and that's why I sorted it
by cumulative time because this tells me
this column tells me how long did this
function take and all of the functions
that it calls to that's what it means by
cumulative okay so if you think of it
like you know your code as an onion and
you have a main function and then that
call some other functions not cause
other functions or a tree or something
the cumulative time gives you well
what's the time of that and everything
below it right whereas total time tells
you what was the time of that function
without all of the stuff below
okay and then the perk all columns just
say well in this case this first case I
only called the function one time so my
total time in my / call time are exactly
the same but the second one I call three
thousand times and so each time it took
less than the resolution of my timing
here took less than one millisecond but
all together those three thousand took
52 milliseconds okay and then it tells
you some stuff here so that's a little
bit much so I'm going to take some of
that stuff out the first line here is
actually not telling me anything useful
about what I'm timing accepts this whole
string one module thing that's that's
saying how long did it take to actually
get into the function so we don't
usually care about that and then this
last one here I don't know why this
changed in some recent version of Python
where the profiler now includes itself i
think that's totally bogus but maybe
maybe you think otherwise so i'm just
going to take a bunch of that stuff out
and we're going to look at a few of
these as we go along yes sir it did
actually and that was the time the time
difference here between lines 1 & 2 so
you there is 40 milliseconds of
iterating over the X range the reason
it's not shown explicitly is because
that's not a function call that's in
line code and what we get here on each
line is a separate function so if we
could we could force it to be shown by
kind of putting that on its own function
but we haven't done that yes
and that's generally true with you know
some minor epsilon differences in adding
the numbers together so yes so the total
time generally should add up here the
thing is that some of these are nested
and nested and nested so it's it's it's
a tree more than a linear addition so so
for example you can see here that well I
don't have much to show you with here
I'll show you later on some more about
how that how that has together so oops
wrong button so I'm going to take out
all the Croft and just show you the
important parts i hope so the way i'm
going to kind of go about some of these
techniques is really give you an
extended example here okay and what
we're going to do is we're going to
we're going to do a standard deviation
so we have an array of numbers a bunch
of floats and it's really easy in Python
you just import numpy make an array of
100 numbers i'm just going to use a
range here because it's easy you could
you can start with a static list of
numbers they're all float so then i'm
going to call num pies it's got an STD
method on the array class tell the
degrees of freedom if you care and then
you get the answer really easy right so
what could go wrong okay so that worked
out really well and I time that it was
great and I say okay now I want to a
standard deviation on 4 billion rows oh
let me do that let me make my numpy raya
dupes something went wrong there hmm
valueerror setting I don't understand
that I the X range worked before I don't
see why it wouldn't work now and it
turns out oh let me try it with you know
zeroes instead of a range oh well I
can't actually make an umpire ray that's
four billion elements long so what do I
do about that i was using numpy because
it was magic and it solved all my
problems and now I I'm stuck right how
do i get my standard deviation over this
many numbers okay so you have to you
have to unpack the magic a little bit
here so what if we could take our big
long call on the numbers
and break it up into segments and figure
out some math on those and then pull all
that back together can I can I
distribute my standard deviation
calculation because because I make the
segment small enough then I can just use
numpy raised right well it turns out you
can so you grab the the local variance
you know standard deviation is variance
from the mean squared and all that if
you if you use the local mean and grab
some of that data then when you bring
them all back together you just kind of
adjust that to the global mean and then
finish your calculation yeah there's all
kinds of epsilon problems and stuff
there but for the moment assume this
works okay but this is a way to kind of
distribute our problem and get around
the memory error that's what we're
trying to solve right so we're going to
put that in code it's really easy it's
easier than writing it in the
mathematical formula so we're going to
have our main run method here we're
going to i'm actually going to as i do
my timing i'm going to lop off four
zeroes here so that it doesn't take days
to actually figure out how long this
takes so we're actually gonna start with
four hundred thousand points in 24
billion but we're still going to segment
it we're going to make a hundred
segments and then we're going to
actually form these and then pass it all
to our standard deviation function
that's what the standard deviation
function looks like we just we're going
to grab the local mean we're going to
find the global mean we're going to do
our adjustment and then put it all
together right pretty straightforward
and when we try that and we run our
profile take 71 seconds which sounds
really great right okay so i got my
answer except i lopped off four zeros
and if i actually think about it and
estimate well how long is this going to
take if i actually didn't wap off all
those zeroes and i have four billion
elements it's going to take me over
eight days to calculate the answer to
this on my little laptop which is
actually pretty quick but like that so
probably not wait eight days for the
problem here so what do you do
well I can't just go down the dump I and
have it fixed all my problems or pandas
what do I do well now you need to learn
a little bit of programming can we get
this from eight days down to a minute
okay and if that if I do that then that
means that I need to be able to do the
smaller toy one here or 400,000 in six
milliseconds can I do that all I need is
a you know 11,000 times speedup can we
do it well let's find out so what we
want to do is optimize our code look at
the code that we wrote that somebody
else isn't you know controlling can we
improve it well this is what profile is
for so if we look at the profile output
we can identify some bottlenecks right
away so first bottleneck here is
actually it really jumps out on us is
this total time 63 seconds to run our
our total method in standard dev top
high why is that taking so much time and
by the way Len there was taking a lot it
wasn't the Len function is being called
a lot and it just doesn't happen to be
quite as long so we're gonna we're going
to investigate that too on the side
let's see why so the first thing I want
you to be able to use its you know you
learn this in year one of cs if you if
you're doing something in a loop and
things in that loop don't change then
don't redo them every time you go
through the loop okay so here's a great
example here's our ears are one of our
helper functions that that grabs all
these variances from the local means
right so we were just doing a really
simple accumulator here we look at every
element in our array calculate the mean
of the array and then we you know
subtract that from our our value of each
cell and do square horse adding that all
up as we go when we look at loop when we
talk about loop and parents you might
think well number one that's about Luke
right so where's the loop in here got a
for loop what's the invariant well first
of all you have to say what is actually
varying and the thing is varying in this
loop is j that's the thing that's
varying so if i have part of I have
anything in my loop here that doesn't
depend on Jay maybe that's the problem
maybe I should pull that out of my loop
okay so over those two lines which one
depends on Jay it's the bottom one this
one here does it depend on Jay at all so
but I'm basically doing here is I'm
saying for every cell and every element
in my array do the same work all over
again that I just did crazy so let's pop
that out of there I'd only do it once
and just reuse the answer every time
okay but I got to make sure that this
actually helped so I'm going to go back
and run my profiling time again look at
that one line of code change we got a 36
times speedup okay I'm trying to make
this obvious for you but sometimes it's
not obvious so our time on the total
function went from 61 seconds down to
you know 1.6 seconds and you can see
that we're calling it not four hundred
thousand times but ten thousand times
that's why we get the speed up okay and
incidentally we did the same thing with
length but I got this great speed up but
if i extrapolate that to my 4 billion
right it's still going to be five point
four hours i can get better so what do i
do next well let's go see if there's
some other loop and variance we can pull
out here and here's one in the standard
of i'm going to highlight this one for
you so it's easy you know here we are
calculating the global mean and we're
doing that once for every part of our
partition so we have to have a hundred
segments then i'm calculating this
global mean hundred times and not only
that i'm calculating it I'm re looping
over these partitions multiple times
inside of itself so let's extract that
loop in my hand take that out of the for
loop how does that work see if that
improves our time hey a 13 x speed on
okay so really simple techniques that
can get you a lot of boosts so you can
see now that our very some and our total
method here are taking milliseconds not
multiple seconds we're doing much better
but we're still good it's still 23
minutes you know maybe you might be
happy with that I think we can get
better so another classic technique and
this is really Python specific if you're
in see you know you're going to be using
whatever library you're using in Python
code written in python is slower than
Python itself because most of Python
itself is written in C okay so python
has to go through this extra
interpretive loop so this is something I
see way too often actually where people
who are used to JavaScript or see or
some of the language they come into
Python and they say well this is how I
do it and see you know i want to
accumulate this value i want to walk
over my my values my array and sum them
up so i'm just going to have an
accumulator that adds doll together
which again great do that in C in
JavaScript but Python provides a sum
function which does that for you and it
does it for you in C and it's been
heavily tuned by 10 Peters and raiment
head and ruin those guys who know far
more than I do about how to tune that
right so this is like you know you're
not going to get any faster than this
you could spend days and days and days
trying to write a faster algorithm in
Python you're never going to get there
so use Python built-ins when you can
because now our total function is just
dropped off the chart it's not 63
milliseconds anymore it's 0 which is as
good as we can get with these tools
right so you can t that some of it has
been taken up though by this sum
function so the cumulative time again
here this is a great example of the
nesting the total function is still
cumulatively taking 15 milliseconds but
all of that is spent just calling some
and then you return the value so it
effectively does nothing
but we're still taking 16 minutes what
do we identify next can we get faster
why yes let's look at our profile output
again here what leaps out that's the
slowest over there it's this Vera some
what can we do about that that's still
kicking us well huh let's try the same
technique here let's see if we can
replace that accumulator where the Sun
and let's be kind of clever about it
some of you may have been to James
Powell's talked about generators so
we're going to use a generator
expression they're really really cool
we're going to some that right makes our
code easier to read let's run that and
see if I uh oh we actually got slower
when we use the Python built-ins what
happened well if you look at this output
a little bit you start to say well
what's this thing that's really slow
that's being called 400,000 times Gen X
/ what is that this is where Python
bites us in the heel sometimes okay and
what you really want to do with python
is if you can write your code in line
and not call functions you really want
to correct your code in line because
function call overhead in python is
unfortunately too high here's an example
so if we're just if we're just timing
the sum function pythons built in some
function right and we run that a few
times takes about 14 15 milliseconds to
you know some list of 10 items a million
times now if I just take it that exact
same function and I wrap it in my total
function instead so all I'm adding is a
call within a call right then it takes
20 21 milliseconds sorry 200 as opposed
to a hundred fifty sorry I misspoke
they're basically what we're adding here
when you unpack all this is it looks
like a small amount we're only adding
what is that I don't know 59 59
I can't remember my orders here now
seconds yeah / call but the problem is
we're calling this 400,000 times and so
that adds up all these things add up and
that's kind of the point of any
optimization work is to reduce those
things that add up so simply the the
function call overhead of calling total
which then call some and then returns
that is doing this to us and the way
that the way that happens is the reason
that's so expensive when you're in
you're running your code and you call
out to a function then python has to
take your current context and store it
and then set up this new context for the
other function and your it's got its own
local variables and it's on state and
its own instruction pointer and whatever
else and then when you return from that
function it throws that away and Riaan
Stan sheets you know pulls back your
previous context and puts it back into
place right yes sir not in pipeline I do
and see you don't want to do recursion
and Python right if you can avoid it so
you have this context switching you know
going on all the time when you call a
function well it turns out back in the
day before we had generator expressions
in Python you might have written the
generator function instead and so this
does exactly what our other code did
only it kind of unpack sit with the
explicit yield statement here and the
problem with this is whenever you yield
inside of a function you're doing
exactly that same context switch
management it's just like you're calling
an external function right and so every
time you yield from this function the
context switches again which is why it
showed up in our profile output as I did
this for in a thousand times right
because I did 400,000 context switches
those are really expensive in Python so
we don't want to do that so how do we
fix that well what we can do very easily
is replace our generator expression up
top with the list comprehension down
below all we have to do is add those on
square brackets okay and that means that
now my code is not going to run on this
context switching yield return you know
call the generator yield the value thing
it's all going to be inline code so it's
not even show up in our output and it's
going to be a lot faster now there are
some memory implications here again look
at you know James Palace talk to learn
about those but if you can do this it's
going to be faster where you need to do
this so now our Vera some function has
gone down to 50 milliseconds when it was
63 so that's its that's kind of an
improvement so we got we got kind of
faster we're still at 13 minutes what's
next ok now you break out the heavy duty
stuff and say ok well python by itself I
don't have to iterate all those things
because when I yes sir
that would have been the same kind of
issue where whether you're using
producer map or any of those folding
operations you paid that function call
overhead every time you you go through
that loop every item then has to go
through that so let's try it let's try
another tack here see if we get any
faster let's use numpy okay great thing
about numpy is you don't have to do a
lot of rewriting to get some benefits
all we're going to do is replace our
total function instead of calling summer
Rae we're going to call the raid some
and similarly very not mean down here
okay and it's got some vector operations
that make things really fast you can
learn about that somewhere else it's
really cool stuff type containers are
faster and great so we got our bear some
from 50 whatever second milliseconds
down to one millisecond just by dropping
in some numpy fantastic I've got a 1.43
speed up there but we're still at nine
and a half minutes what else can I do
remember I wanna get this down under a
minute oops well the interesting thing
here is our profiling out but really
changed here and before it seemed like
it took almost no time to make our
arrays and all the time was spent in
analyzing our arrays but now it looks
like most of our time is actually in
this numpy array constructor so we just
we did get a little faster but not as
much as we expected to because if you
look at that and if you take out the
actual numpy or a construction times we
actually got to our six millisecond
target and we should be able to do this
in one minute right so what happened
well we spend all our time making those
numpy raised so just for fun let's take
where we are right now and let's try
four billion of these things see if it
you know we if we if we hit our six
millisecond target you know let's see
how long this takes oh yeah
we can't just month it up like that we
can make a four billion element numpy
array so now we have to actually do our
segmentation properly and we're actually
going to take the opportunity at the
same time to paralyze it so we have
multiple cores working on the same
problem okay that's the basics of that
are really easy in Python there's lots
more advanced strategies you can get on
to you know farm this out to multiple
machines I'm just going to show you the
multi processing module which does it on
one machine so at least you can take
advantage of multiple cores because
python has the same called the global
interpreter lock which means yeah you
might think you have threads but you
know really have threats okay so you got
to run on multiple drop multiple
processes so all we have to do is drop
in this pool thing which actually when I
construct the pool here it actually goes
in and it knows how many cores I'm
running so it knows how many workers to
start up here and I'm going to I'm going
to tell it to run this run one function
and then you know parse out all my
pieces and then bring it all back
together kind of a MapReduce style here
so this is what the run one function
looks like we're actually in take
advantage of some memory mapping to get
this off disc a little bit faster we
hope and I'm going to change what I'm
returning a little bit from each of the
pieces so I'm going to I'm going to get
back the total and the length so then i
can calculate the local mean and then
i'm going to turn this v variable here
which is the local variance right and
then we're going to go to our
adjustments once we reduce it all and
then our standard deviation function
looks pretty much the same we're just
going to unpack the data a little bit
differently we're still doing exactly
the same adjustments here put it all
back together oh I didn't work out too
well this is actually six times slower
why is that well it turns out that the
multi processing module has some
overhead of course to ship the commands
out to each of the workers and the
gather them all back and you know it
ships the command out and then sits
there and waits for the response to come
back and puts it all back together so
this is actually slower than than what I
had before but I wonder
if you know looking at the the actual
functions there that are slow well it's
threaded up high and it's pulled up high
map and it's just thread lock acquire
stuff and it seems to be all waiting for
the workers so maybe that's not going to
get much worse when I scale up maybe
that's a little bit of noise when I
actually get to 4 billion items so hey
could it be insignificant let's try it
it actually is rather insignificant and
we went from I don't remember we're at
before but we're at you know more than
this and we're now really really close
to getting this done on four billion
elements in under a minute okay there's
still a couple things here it turns out
that using profile now got harder
because I'm running these workers that
are being spawned by by Python and
they're running in remote processes so
have to be a little bit more careful now
about profiling because back here I was
just profiling the head node now how do
I profile each my workers well I can't
just do it interactively so I have to
have to take a couple other little tools
here that the profile module offers and
actually dumped my results to a file so
that's what PR effed up 50 thing is so
I'm going to dump the stats to a file
and then unfortunately it's a little bit
harder I have to be a little bit more
mechanical about reading that file and
sorting it and getting my results but so
that's what i did i just took I took one
of the hundred workers and I profile
just one of them and I said okay what's
this one doing and it turns out that
it's doing a lot of work in some for
some reason it's taking two seconds in
this you funk reducing that's weird why
would the sum function be so slow well
it turns out that it's slow because
we're doing the memory mapping so when
you call that mem map function there it
does very little work just to set up
some pointers to your data on disk it
doesn't actually read all that in the
RAM at that point it's not until I call
the sum function that it says oh now I
need to stay to let me pull it all in
around and that's why some is taking so
long there
and it's taking you know a couple
seconds each which means over 100
segments it's taking 200 seconds but I
have four cores so it's actually 50
seconds you know for each one of these
that's that's the total damage done by
this approach now if you look at it yeah
I'm taking 67 whatever seconds but 50 of
those are just loading my data right so
I've gone from a parallel is a
parallelization problem now I get a
serialization problem and if I could get
rid of that somehow then I could
actually do the math the actual math I'm
interested in much more quickly right so
let's just throw in something I heard
once that block was really it was faster
than um pies native serialization format
so let me throw it in there triad is
some compression that's what that sea
level thing is so we're just going to
we're going to change how we save and
load these files off a disk let's see if
that doesn't better Wow let's try it yes
it does do better and in fact it does
phenomenally better now we were shooting
for a minute you know to get our total
done here and this is over the four
billion element array you know we were
shooting for a minute and we got down to
26 seconds and you can see here you know
that the the calls in the head have not
changed because we're showing you the
head node here but the total time
definitely has so we've just done we've
achieved our goal right so how do we do
that just to recap well we had some time
tested general program techniques so we
took our loop and variants out right we
use some language built-ins like some
and so on and we really tried to reduce
our Python function calls call see all
you want reduce your Python function
calls and we use some specific you know
Python libraries to kind of drop in and
make everything faster so we use a numpy
for vector operations which are always
going to be faster we use
multiprocessing for parallelization and
we use this boss pack for compression so
we sped up our calculation so it runs in
not three percent point zero three
percent of the time that's 27 thousand
times faster than when we started okay
so when you really want to go beyond the
boundaries of what Python gives you out
of the box or even numpy your sniper
these other pandas or whatever give you
out of the box you're kind of in the
wild West's of some things but you know
if you just learn a few techniques like
this to make your code faster and this
also applies to you know hey i'm using
numpy and all these things but i have to
write my own management software for all
that stuff well that needs to be kind of
fast sometimes too you know that could
be your bottleneck so this really
applies you know across the board make
your make your your code run faster you
know if you if you want your code to run
in eight days more power to ya maybe
that gives you job security but I won't
mind to run in whatever that was 26
seconds ok any questions yes how can I
be calm if I go down this road 0 minutes
ok so is a big question so was this my
personal experience not for this
particular problem because we solve
different pieces of it at different
times so when I got to this particular
problem we already had ninety percent
that's all so so this is you know I
actually had a hard time making this be
slow enough because I'm so used to
making it fast so that was kind of a fun
exercise academic goes slower but then
you know it I found that it's really a
different story when even when you're
talking about the general programming
techniques which really are universal
versus hey I dropped in this library and
it made a lot faster so generally I kind
of like to think of that as I mean it's
really two different mindsets of how can
i how can i make my stuff better versus
how can i grab somebody else's stuff and
use it quickly you know it's kind of the
integrator mind said yes okay wait for
my so sort of two questions that are
related first was for the
multiprocessing part I'm assuming that
you guys have experimented with other
things like zeromq and I'm assuming
they're faster but do they work with see
profile like are you able to profile the
different calls the parallel calls to 0
mq the way you did with multiprocessing
pool right yes and in fact at my current
company we are using zeromq and we do we
are able to do exactly the same
profiling techniques the one thing you
have to be a little bit careful about is
if just like it was harder to profile a
remote process they get spawned
automatically you have to do a little
extra work there with things like zeromq
and other stuff that starts threads that
you don't know about and other things
and those are a little bit harder to
profile you have to you have to know
when to attach your profiler which is
pretty early yeah harder to do on an ad
hoc basis any other questions Oh
simple old-school question when you're
competing the variances you did a
subtraction followed by square i
actually haven't played with this in
python would it been faster to basically
multiply that that subtracted amount
times each other versus doing the doing
the square operation it may have been I
actually didn't time that yeah it to do
x times X Ryland x squared that maybe
and that'd be a great thing to time at
time with time at or see profile I
actually I kind of worked around that
problem by just saying well I'm going to
go back to numpy eventually you know so
it's going to do a heck of a lot faster
than anything I could do in Python it
really in a for loop okay well thank you
very much free time hope it was useful
you